ciekawe, że autentyczne, folkowe
autentyczny
jest to już zrobione ręcznie
zachowaliśmy tutaj naszą tradycję i styl
przodkowie
[muzyka]
nie mogli nic zrobić, zabijając ich
zakazać
Malanka i Szewczenko To jest nasze
ponieważ nasza pamięć była w okolicy
ruch i obiad
wygonili nas z miasta
to powinien być film najzimniejszy z was
Patrzeć
[muzyka]
z jednego z rogów
chłopaki są między sobą i decydują, kto jest silniejszy
kto tu udźwignie ciężar
które moglibyśmy wydać lub walczyć, jest konieczne
walka
śmierć
symboliczna śmierć, ręka w górę
W ten sposób najczęściej umieramy
tacy młodsi chłopcy i diabeł pasuje i
cholernie pasuje i ten czarny też pasuje
starsi chłopcy są trochę bardziej regionalni
piekło, głównie jak wioska młodych ludzi
dziewczyny lubią być uderzane widłami czy czymś takim
walka o trzymanie się czegoś takiego jest nasza
już tak zgonów. Śmierci trafiają także do dziewcząt
żartował
w skrócie jest strażnik, cóż, więc tak
to była zabawa
to była kiedyś tajemnica
Futra nie wiedziały, kto jest kim, po co od drugiego
poszukiwany
Cóż, to jest tajne, dopóki nie zaczęli walczyć
Zawsze tak rozkazywałem, gdy walczyłem
rzucił ich do tego stopnia, że ​​zdjęli maskę
podkreślono, że nawet mu się to nie podobało
dlatego nie należy po tym zdejmować maski
o tym, jak zakończy się Malanka
kwiaty nie będą mieszane, nie było ich
tak, to jest dla
piękności i czasami już wyróżniają tę
Kto ma taki kwiatek z tamtego kąta
z góry ludzie już jest tego więcej Ale gdzie
Denis
byłoby tu dobrze
niebiesko-żółty ale
to jest to jest to jest wciąż radzieckie
symbol
kwiaty
Na Ukrainie występuje czerwono-czarna czerwień
czarny
Udajemy się teraz do Malanki, aby spotkać się z kobietą Yaka
zakłada zamek
a potem około półtorej godziny
założyć później
wszyscy do niej przychodzą i się kręcą
postacie i stamtąd pozostaje wędrówka
wieś
będzie kot
oddychać, że jesteś zamknięty
[muzyka]
była piękna, Malanka wybiera chłopaków
dzięki czemu był dokładnie lepszy od Malanki
nasz kącik
[muzyka]
wszyscy bohaterowie Malanki to diabły śmierci
Żyd
Następnie
Sortując, trafiają do niej błyskawicą
dom
biorą błyskawicę i idą do księdza
błogosławieństwo
[muzyka]
kolędowanie
mała dziewczynka i tata Tam dają im takie małe
stół jest umieszczony na podwórku i tam
Vodichki Kto to jest, bo jest już całkiem rano
zjadłem przekąskę i poszedłem na wycieczkę
Musiałam rozebrać męża, żeby usiąść
jutro
[oklaski]
nasza rodzina
NA
wybaczmy
Och, raduj się, ziemio
żył, urodził się
[muzyka]
kolędowanie w pobliżu klubu
przedsiębiorcy również akceptują błyskawice
nadal tak
tradycja kto bierze ślub w tym roku
Chłopaki
pokazać także białoruską błyskawicę i
wszystkie trzy Malanki zbierają się na lunchu i
udać się na stadion, na którym się odbywa
walka ludowa jest ludowa z tradycji
nasza wiejska walka
[muzyka]
jest walka
ciągnie
kto pierwszy walczy, mamy trzech
Narożniki
[muzyka]
walka będzie wystarczająco długa, aby tam walczyć
i nosi dwa niedźwiedzie
jest 4-5 diabłów
[muzyka]
minimum dwie godziny
każdy róg ma takie szorstkie wsparcie
duży
jak w piłce nożnej
[oklaski]
po tej walce
każdy róg przypada na swoje własne rogi i
kolędują tam, gdzie jest dziewczyna
potem idę do Malanki na spotkanie
Brazylijska piękna dziewczyna przyjmuje w domu
wszystko, a potem po tym przyjęciu idą dalej
tańce, które robią Ten zakątek, który był zajęty
pierwsze miejsce
Waszym zdaniem Czy Malanka daje mieszkańcom
wioski inspiracji na przyszły rok
Cóż, wszyscy czekają
że Malanka tym razem już dobiegła końca
o jutrzejszym poświęceniu
słowa
oznacza, że ​​to poświęcenie już się zakończyło
zielony
[muzyka]
[oklaski]
wideo